two-time Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP MVP of the league in 1998
Wow that's 20 is that really 20 years
ago in Super Bowl of his Super Bowl
championship and MVP season the Pro
Football Hall of Famer thrilled Davis
good to see you sir 20 years ago 20
years ago you were the MVP of the league
that is true I just try to maintain you
know what I'm thinking maybe one day it
may never happen but I think like
psychologically I tell myself that
they're gonna have something that
reverses or stops aging okay and maybe
I'll be able to play again so I that's
but that's the only thing I can do to
work out cause otherwise well if that
happens then you're gonna have to go to
Phillip Lindsey and ask him for not
asking for may just go give it to me and
say hey man here you go
reunite you with your number um well he
texts to me okay and so I called him
back and we have we had a conversation
well he asked for it yeah yeah no I mean
and so that the third the first or the
first thing I'm like why that's pretty
cool like the dude called me for it okay
cuz our days Mladic you know nice
Millennials are different players are
different you know they'll just go take
the number and then really don't have a
history or understanding about the
number and he had foreknowledge of but
he's from Denver went to see you and
Matt just the way he was impressive you
know talking to him on the phone and so
it was like amen no doubt I think but
they netic that really stood out to me
was his story right and kind of having a
a player an underdog who wasn't drafted
but opening day is essentially a starter
I mean wasn't D starter but he got a lot
of burn you know caught a touchdown pass
and in training camp I know how it is to
go to training camp and be undrafted or
be a late round pick and to have to be
noticed at practice and people they
raved about him
entire preseason and so I'm like okay I
gotta check this kid out okay I
researched him and kind of followed him
and every conversation from dimers camp
was Philip Lindsay is it true he's a
real deal and more impressive was not
only on the field but him as a person
and so that was verified when I talked
to him and I said man this is this makes
sense because it's easy to give your
number to somebody who's projected to be
great right a first-round pick second
overall pick whatever that's easy but to
me the number 30 kind of represents the
underdog the guy that didn't have a shot
it's not supposed to be here you know so
I thought it was fitting for me to say
okay yeah go ahead and rock it man and
and make it your own so there was no
part of you at all that sits there and
says no because you look it's not on the
kid this is not on the kid why why isn't
that number somewhere where nobody gets
it I mean was that is that not at all
well you gotta remember Jamie remember
David Bruton played for the Broncos for
I think seven or eight years he was a
safety and he wore 30 so he wore from
2009 until like 2016 or something like
that and so the number 30 was numbers
hanging up anywhere I know that right
it's been said I'm trying to say that it
hey man listen if they didn't want
somebody wearing it they were [ __ ]
it's not on me
the numbers then a number doesn't make
me you know it doesn't make a person it
doesn't make me I look at you know where
you got like 88 right in Dallas right oh
I know
our Irv was the one who's like told I
think he kind of told Dez you should put
it on I don't remember what it was I
thought well that came I don't know I
shouldn't say that cuz I don't know how
that all came about it's just again for
me just watching a game and let's say
Bruton made it I didn't even know this
okay and I when I follow the NFL like
anybody else like or more than more than
most I didn't sit there think when you
made a tank well that's T DS number but
when somebody's running I think that's
the difference you know the position is
what it is right yeah just see number 31
in the ball in that uniform and he did
one game
and he really did that number very
nicely yes he did I expect them to
continue listen I like seeing the 30 out
there I think what what it does if
you're if you don't know and it kind of
brings it back up right it becomes a
topic of conversation you're talking
about
yeah there you have to kind of research
and say oh wait a minute somebody that's
what at 30 and and so maybe it may be in
a strange way it kind of keeps you
relevant and I don't know that hey the
Denver's taking on the Raiders this
weekend at home could go to two and oh
here four against the Raiders team that
played a quality first half against the
Rams and then yes fell apart you know
and then to me it will be it would be
helpful for Von Miller to have a good
game for two reasons one up for the
obvious Exodus and those reasons and
being in Derek cards face but to the
guys over on the other side once and we
used to have son oh yeah we it's a
similar player to that how long does
that last you think that linger that
feeling until you start winning until
you start consistently winning because
the the trust of the players in that
locker room are saying wait a minute we
you just traded away our best player so
now we have to trust you with the plan
the overall plan that you're gonna get
us to where we want to go right and if
you keep making moves that don't bear
fruit early man it will erode a locker
room like no other and so if they don't
start winning games and if it comes down
to games where they can make it they
could have used you know Mac and lil
Cleo Mac hmm I'm a classic he's he's a
panther Khalil Mac that's right confused
right then then they'll be like every
time something happens his name's gonna
come up just like this week so yeah they
just gonna start winning games that's
really it and then that I would imagine
that's the same situation for the
Steelers Terrell Davis here on the Rich
Eisen show with levy on bail sitting out
and you know it's not you know I listen
when left held out I agree with with hit
the game plan right you know you hold
out you try to get more money I think at
this point you start the question
waiting mitt there's two things that
that could happen number one is that
you're losing a lot of money right now
and I don't know if you can ever make
that up but number two you allow
somebody to shine while you're out and
James Conner had a heck of a game and so
every day or every week he has a good
game and live Bell is holding out he is
going to be more and more moving the
needle to them saying listen we're just
gonna trade Bell he's a cheaper version
of him he's not quite left no listen
let's just be honest he's not that but
he is a serviceable back that with time
I think he could be could be
I wouldn't say special I think he could
be a really good running back and so
it's dicey man it's it's dicey does the
situation he's in and what would you do
a few right now if I was Bell yes sir I
want to sign that debt franchise tag oh
you how to sign that thing a long time
ago I mean I would've held out how to
try to try to get more right but I
wouldn't have missed regular season
games for it yeah it's coming up it's
gonna be if he doesn't sign by Saturday
4:00 p.m. Pittsburgh time it'll be over
1.6 million dollars oh my god we didn't
make that kind of money I didn't make
that kind of money plan and and so I but
I'm never and it's different so I'm not
saying what he should do I'm only
speaking from what I would do yes and
that is I think part of it too is it I
don't want to let my teammates down you
know at the end of the day I want to
make sure that I'm there and I don't
want to let them down because we're all
in this thing together and I get it and
people talk about the business of it you
got to get paid
he should be compensated because he's
one of the best backs if not the best
back in Italy but they didn't get a deal
done at this point
and you know I feel bad for him and you
know cuz his teammates are now coming
out and now there's a divide that
starting to happen based on the fact
that he's not think you know in the
building and so how is that gonna work
out when he comes back well they're all
saying right now hey well welcome back
with open arms absolutely we can't wait
for him to come back and he's telling em
JD you know Maurice jones-drew
that yeah you know I heard what they had
to say
but you know when I come back I'm just
you know everything's gonna be fine
is that what he said sort of yeah that
would live said this is what love told
told Maurice jones-drew
which you know he told this to our buddy
damage actor and his football program
has also read on nfl.com so way to keep
up with what's going on mjd said he said
I was disappointed quoting Bell he was
like I was disappointed they went out
and spoke about my contract
understandably so I still want them to
do well there's still my guys I work
with and guys that I put this extra work
with blood sweat and tears like I still
want them to do well but as you're
pointing out maybe not so well this week
against the the Chiefs right because
that's what the Steelers are gonna do
they're thinking let's just show that we
can win without him
week one didn't work they didn't lose
without I didn't win either neither and
then week two we'll see how it goes and
if week two they win without him you
know the the serve is now on on their
racket
if not then bail can sit there but I
also think it's not only winning I think
it's it's James Connor it's really
focused focused on his his performance
and he was really really good it was big
been really turning the ball over Connor
did also have an awful fumble yeah they
they crumbled in the fourth quarter
asked the poll question of Terrell Davis
Chris Brockman please why don't you who
most needs a win this week TD looking at
Dallas the Giants Atlanta New Orleans
Pittsburgh out of those teams or sir
out of those five to five teams we say
it again most who most needs a win
Cowboys Saints Giants Steelers Falcons
so you got 401 teams in 100 and one team
who needs it I would say out of those
teams the Saints needs it the most right
now after what happened to them week one
that was the tops nobody saw that one
coming
Ryan Fitzpatrick had a field day career
numbers across the board I mean the
passer rating was like through the roof
158 or something I mean you get
embarrassed like that at home in your
own building I know it's a vision
opponent but you got to bounce back you
didn't win and they plan to browse this
week night and then oh no
expected them they they'll come out and
give him some some troubles but they
little to the Browns at home at home to
go on.200 and to in that division at
home to that would not be good so they
needed they needed porcini but all the
Falcons as well I mean if they lose in
division to Carolina I mean they'd have
lost it the Eagles in Carolina but I'd
be a hard one to know but those are I
mean you can it's it's a tough loss but
Philly you you almost talked it up as
you kind of knew that you didn't pick
them to win that game did you no I did I
did Lana to win that game you did I did
because based off what what was the
based off of the fact that we saw last
year a surprise on a banner raising
night based on the fact that Atlanta
came awfully close to winning in that
building and based on the misguided fact
that I thought that Atlanta would have
spent at least every last minute of the
offseason figuring out how to crack the
red zone code and instead they did not
and I was sorely disappointed it seemed
like they tried the same formula right I
mean with julio jones you get on there
here's a problem I mean when you're when
you're the Falcons he's struggling a red
zone it's two things I look at you're
tight in right you're tired hands have
to be really good or you gotta have a
back that is kind of a bruiser
that can you know get those tough yards
in the red zone and they don't really
have they don't have those you know
they've got smaller backs and they don't
have that big guy like a like a blunt or
even a bale or you know a Sikh they have
you know freedom is really good a coma
is really good but they're kind of small
backs and and you know so red zone and
red and here's the other thing too if
there's a psychological thing that it's
hard to crack when you don't have
success in the red zone and you know it
and once you get on there again and the
more and more you don't have success it
just piles up and now we get on there
you're like oh here we go again that's
why here we go again look we all know
about different sports and how
the intensity level ratchets up as you
move down a season or whatever but the
NFL there's nothing like the NFL when
you go week to week or year to here and
the same issues crop up or new issues
crop up because you didn't say fill out
your roster like the Cowboys did at the
wide receiver position for back I mean
again that's why I'm seeing it that I
think the Cowboys need to win this game
to fall Owen to sit there on Sunday
Night Football lose the Giants when they
have all these shiny toys at offense
that the Cowboys are missing out there I
worry with you with the Cowboys but the
caps so I say the Saints because there
they were like a Superbowl favorite they
were a favorite in a lot of people's
mind the Cowboys are not a favorite at
least not that I've heard out of the
Metroplex
maybe not but sitting down there and hey
Irv Irv put him in the playoffs and he's
giving voice to what I think a lot of
cowboys fans think well that's docked at
Zeek that defense they talked about the
defense being better let me tell you let
me tell you okay
planned as a back and win the year we
lost John Elway alright when you don't
have balance you don't have a
quarterback to scare somebody you don't
have receivers we had really good right
wide receivers in the Hall of Fame tied
in and Shannon Sharpe if when it's just
a one-man show or if it's just a
one-dimensional offense you feel like as
her back so I came in was like my fifth
year John had retired I thought they had
13 players on defense that's how many
people were stacked in the box that stop
the run that's what Zika is gonna be
dealing with mm-hmm if you can't
threaten them with any type of passing
game that people are that they respect
that ain't that that formal of a good
defense and a guy that can run that can
only take you so far are you saying
Brian Griese wasn't the right guy
Michigan man wasn't right guy so you're
saying no I'm saying that he didn't
prove himself to be the right guy by the
way he sits down he sits down he goes
how's Michigan doing this year we played
if we had played Austin Peay week one oh
here we go
instead of Notre Dame TD and I huge
George Dobbins his girlfriend is now
living girlfriends at Georgia
smile hold on a second hold on a second
house Cal State Long Beach doing hey man
watch your mouth watch your mouth over
there
undefeated we have lost the game since
1991 see you leave them and it's kind of
a we have not lost the game since 1991
how many programs can say that zero
thank you very much the programs have to
exist in order to be able to say that
all right see you're a Georgia Bulldog
yes because he's now moved in with a
girl who's your fan yeah you go it's
contagious like that yeah we had a nice
little beat down on South Carolina last
week it was good that's good for us that
was good yeah very good and before I let
you go you're wearing a Hall of Fame
golf shirt all professional Pro Football
Hall of Fame golf shirt yeah what I
don't have a lot of shirts by the way so
my just thrown I throw stuff in there
it's all good a lot I do want to get
this out here what will it mean to you
to see the bowling family next year oh
man I'd stay a lot a lot packed yet well
it's gonna happen I'm confident that
it's gonna happen usually when you're
coming out of a committee yeah it's your
you know you're going to be in yeah who
came out of the contributor committee
along with Gil Brandt so deal Brad he
definitely knows your your your combo
talk to him yes I'm just he knows like
some of the most random stuff about you
I know what school you went to the guy
that was across town and yeah
interesting stuff yeah he knows socrates
is vertically he probably has a little
bio you to socrates vertical leap is a
great fantasy 50 men but what will it
mean to you alive the bone family yeah a
lot you know I'm excited about it
because you know just all the years I
was with Pat Bowlen and what he's done
for not only the Broncos man but the
city of Denver Colorado the the National
Football League you know in a phone
network network committees everything
he's done now people get a chance to
really see what Pat what he's done like
what his legacy really is they think
about him he doesn't want credit for
anything never did he always stayed in
the shadows and just weren't important
to make sure everything was first-class
as it can be
he only cared about other people and not
himself very gracious to me and my
family and took care of me when I was at
the Super Bowl xxxii in San Diego I had
a huge list of people that needed to go
to the game and Pat was like took care
of all of that stuff man my family tree
I have just he was just so gracious
ma'am and and it really had a
relationship with him not like an owner
player but more like like two people
respected what they did so yeah it's
gonna be in the world of me I can't wait
do it wait for it to go down guy now the
Broncos family is gonna be really
emotional it's gonna be a great day and
I just hope his bust has like a
perfectly dimpled tie involved maybe
just a collar of a mink coat coming
around he's the boss I really mean coat
like when when it became a big deal
because it's just too much attention
it's just great good to see you Terrell
Davis Thank You Man and we were at the
NFL Network just like me
yes we have but we have a pick'em show
on Friday that's right yeah it's you and
it's Aaron Cox Carelli right it's we
have Dan Haley that's right and you and
Cynthia Freeland it's right Cynthia with
with the the model yes takes all the
games she nails it ever since it's good
to see you too RL Davis at Terrell
underscore Davis the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience